je t'ai québécois faut acheter local
très important pour nos entreprises
québécoises
c'est important pour nous travailleurs
travailleuses québécoises de ces
entreprises là et donc le panier bleus
se succèdent visibles
il y a un an avec la fermeture de
certains magasins et l'augmentation du
commerce en ligne
on voulait donner un coup de pouce aux
entreprises d'ici nous ce qu'on donne la
chance est vraiment de donner de la
visibilité des petits commerçants qui
des fois son pote perçue par la
clientèle autour comme un marchand qui
fait du commerçant en ligne des règles
l'expérience panne et bleus aient été
fondés à un peu denses une certaine
urgence je pense que l'intention du
pénible était très très bonne
lorsqu'on arrive sur le pagne ébloui une
liste de deux commerces québécois mais
qui ne vend pas nécessairement des
produits qui est l'écho des produits
canadiens l'épicerie a en effet constaté
que parmi les aliments disponibles dans
le panier bleus beaucoup ne sont pas
d'ici ce qui est important de noter
surtout section les commerçants locaux
que sur lesquels on travaille ce ne sont
pas les produits
c'est vraiment les commerces
le consommateur qui veut acheter local
doit donc tenter de s'y retrouver
mais la notion de local c'est quoi 50 km
100 200 la province le pays
ma définition à moi du local est
toujours en lien avec la notion de
nationalisme alimentaire donc du produit
au québec où produit près du québec
normalement je m'en rends pour dire
qu'un produit au québec c'est local mais
c'est pas tant la distance que l'idée
philosophie politique qui a derrière de
dire jeudi choquants vous achetez un
produit d'ici c'est les gens qui
travaillent ici c'est des gens qui
payent des impôts ici c'est des gens qui
permettent de construire des écoles des
ponts des ce que vous voudrez bertrand
noël dirige la coopérative en direct de
la ferme qui distribue chaque semaine
des paniers d'épicerie constitué de
produits locaux à plus de 80 familles de
montréal ça s'il panique
famille
à manger pour une semaine on va
retrouver normalement au moins six gros
repas protéines et depuis que monsieur
legault a prononcé le mot locale je veux
dire j'ai vu moi une déferlante
d'entreprise
arrivé sur internet achetez local
on vend locale puisque local chaussures
local masque locaux tout est devenu
local du jour au lendemain
des outils existent pour s'y retrouver
dans beaucoup d'épicerie et de marché on
affiche clairement la provenance de
certains produits d'ici les tailleurs
d'alimentation quand on fait un beau
travail de mettre des produits en
évidence il faut se souvenir que le lait
les oeufs la volaille sont des produits
canadiens
donc nos produits laitiers sont des
produits du canada et est même souvent
du québec disons le puis ensuite en
aliments du québec est un gage de
qualité
la certification aliments du québec
reste l'une des méthodes les plus
fiables
ça fait longtemps qu'on travaille à
définir ce qui est local et c'est
accepter aussi par toute l'industrie
toute la filière bioalimentaire
donc c'est ça aussi qui est intéressant
et ça commence à être connu et reconnu
du consommateur pour obtenir le logo
aliments du québec
le produit doit contenir au moins 85 %
d'ingrédients québécois
pour les produits contenant moins de 85
% d'ingrédients dit si il y à la
certification aliments préparés au
québec
mais cela ne veut pas dire qu'on peut
faire n'importe quoi quand on doit 10
des ingrédients en quantité suffisante
au québec on peut donner par exemple les
pommes le poulet pour encourager la
transformation à utiliser la production
de 6 mai dans la définition d'aliments
préparés au québec où si on dit que
quand c'est disponible en quantité
suffisante au québec faut le prendre au
québec
vous pourriez pas faire par exemple
porter ou poulet ou importés au port
avec du porc importée ou du poulet
importé
à titre d'exemple parce que la ressource
première n'est pas disponible ici des
jus de fruits tropicaux des produits de
café ou de chocolat et des huiles
d'olive peuvent obtenir la certification
préparés au québec
sa vie il ya un mouvement sur l'achat
local s'est pas seulement au québec
moi j'ai suivi c'est à travers le monde
des paniers il ya des paniers bleus il
ya des paniers de tous les couleurs à
travers le monde les trois quarts des
consommateurs européens disent
privilégier les aliments locaux
mais pour la majorité d'entre eux un
aliment locales et produits ou fabriqués
dans leur région fois dans le pays
nos voisins du sud encourage l'achat
d'aliments américain avec la notion de
produit des états unis ou fabriqués aux
états unis et ils vont encore plus loin
avec le buy american act qui pénalise
l'achat de certains produits importés à
l'ouest nos voisins ont le logo en
ontario terre nourricière
les gens pris aussi de plus en plus
conscience pendant cette crise là
convient toujours actuellement que
la fabrication locale et la
transformation alimentaire faire
travailler des gens d'ici dans le fond
faire bouger notre économie c'est
important de penser qu'on va aller 100%
local je pense que c'est une utopie
je pense que ce qu'il faut c'est que
notre dollar alimentaires soient
utilisés à bon escient quand c'est le
temps ça serait quoi donc quand ce cas
qu'on est en saison qu'on peut manger
québécois on le fait quand on n'est pas
en 16 ans mais il ya des efforts qui
sont possibles mais pour le restant de
l'année
on peut tricher un peu le panier bleus
va continuer de se transformer pour vous
aider à poser un geste solidaire dont
vous pouvez être fiers je pense que
d'avoir un organe qui fait la promotion
justement de ce mouvement alors je pense
que c'est très important pour le québec
faut pas la regarder seulement comme un
site web en fait voulu regarder vraiment
comme un organisme qui fait la promotion
de l'achat local
on voit quatre seulement il ya un
argument pour les produits locaux pour
pour les produits du terroir pour ce
qu'ils fabriquent et au québec
je pense qu est ce qui va être important
c'est que une fois cette part déterminé
que tous ces bons réflexes qu'on a
développés d'acheter des produits du
québec demeurent et que les épiciers
continue à nous offrir ses produits à
bien les identifier à les mettre en
évidence
à chaque fois qu'on encourage une ferme
qu'on encourage des artisans qu'on
encourage même des restaurateurs peu
importe c'est de l'argent qui circule
ici donc et qui finalement nous revient
directement
[Musique]